let's face the facts okay we have been
brainwashed Disney movies romance novels
our imaginations everything in the media
has led us to believe that one day we
will find the perfect person and what a
bunch of bullshit I mean just once I
wish they'd show a realistic romantic
comedy that demonstrates what
relationships really are like I am very
emotionally upset right now but I am
doing my best
you're tickling my feelings nothing
hardball because I respect you
I don't live and appreciate your
self-control and I'm willing to work on
things we disagree on because I believe
[Music]
everything that I've consumed has led me
to believe that men can read my mind so
when I say I'm fine I expect them to
hear I want you to reassure me that you
didn't mean to hurt my feelings
and that wasn't your intention and I
want you to give me a really big hook
there maybe some chocolate ice cream
when really all they hear is I'm fine
you grow up thinking that you're gonna
find this perfection and yet we're not
perfect so how can we expect someone
else to be some dangerous precedent to
set I think you just have to find one
person who's worth putting up with for
the rest of your life
I'll see you next week stay awesome
Gotham